c'est la russie qui amorce une
désescalade des tensions avec l'ukraine
moscou a commencé à retirer ses troupes
de la frontière ukrainienne vladimir
poutine se dit également prêt à recevoir
à n'importe quel moment ce sont ses mots
son homologue ukrainien volodimir à
zelensky pour évoquer allaitantes des
relations bilatérales
je propose d'écouter la porte parole de
la diplomatie russe elle s'est exprimé
chez nos confrères de rtl 2 h
ouiiiii mais nous avons le droit
d'organiser les mêmes exercice planifié
que tout autre pays du monde et nous les
effectuons sur notre sol en l'occurrence
il n'y a aucune différence entre nous et
d'autres états souverains qui agissent
ainsi
pourquoi nos exercices militaires font
ils l'objet d'une attention particulière
michael sata chebbi des pantalons jetons
à protéger nier mon nom et je crois que
la réponse est claire parce que pendant
des années
l'occident est en premier lieu
washington mais aussi les institutions
de bruxelles font de l'agitation en
prétendant que la russie est un état
avec les soeurs winick akdag nous
n'avons jamais provoqué aucun
effondrement internationale aucun fléau
mondial
cela n'a jamais eu lieu alors que
d'autres pays s'y adonnent des pays qui
pour quelques raisons que ce soit nous
qualifie aujourd'hui d'agresseurs
d'agresseurs historique il fallait c'est
un fake
ce n'est pas vrai